[Music]  morbius appeared first as an antagonist  in the amazing spider-man in 1971 and  eventually evolved into more of an  anti-hero if you're gonna run  do it now  for years before that marvel was  actually forbidden from using characters  considered more on the supernatural side  so it was a really big deal when morbius  finally made his debut there's something  inside of me  who wants to hunt  [Music]  and consume blood  he was part of a much darker turn within  marvel one that fortunately fans fully  embraced after all everyone loves a good  monster story  there's something about the character  that stoked people's imaginations  it really can grab a hold of you  johnny  that certainly did with me  see you in theaters  [Music]